So, there's one other interesting thing we can do with find.
And going back to the original description of find, we said,
well, find returns the first position, there might other occurrences. And
we might want to find those other occurrences. The way to find
those other occurrences is, we can actually pass in an extra
parameter. So, instead of just passing in one string, we can
pass in the second parameter, which is going to be a
number. Then when we pass in a number what find will output
is the number of the position in the search
string, where the target string appears, the first occurrence after
that position. So, it'll give the first occurrence where
the target string appears in the search string, but starting
from whatever position we pass in this number. So,
if we pass in zero, well, it would start from
the beginning, that would mean the same thing as
the original find. If we pass in the position here,
it would start from there and would still output
the same value we found before. If we start from
here, well then, it wouldn't find this occurrence, because this
occurrence starts after that position, it would find this one.
So, here's an example. We'll use this quote
attributed to George Danton during the French Revolution. Translated
loosely, it means audacity, more audacity, always audacity.
I should mention that Danton was actually executed, so
whether you want to follow this advice or
not depends on how you think things worked out
for him. But if we do a find
with danton, passing in audace with no extra parameter,
we'll get position five which is the position
where audace starts. The first occurrence of audace
is found. [NOISE] If we pass in a number as well, well if we pass in zero,
we'll also get five. That's because starting from
position zero, we find audace at position five. If
we pass in the number five, we'll still
get five as the result, starting from position five,
we find audace at position five. If we
pass in a number higher than five, let's pass
in six, well now find is looking for
an occurrence starting from position six, which is here.
Instead of finding the first occurrence of audace,
it'll find the first one that occurs after position
six, which is the one here at position 25.
Let's just print out the string from position six
to confirm that. So, printing from position six to the end, we see that the
quote is udace, encore. And so on.
I'll spare you from my poor French pronunciation,
and that's why it found audace at
this location, which is position 25. The result
always counts from the beginning of the
original string. Position 25 of the original string,
which is where it found the second occurrence of audace. So if we pass in 25.
We'll get 25 as the output, finding the position where this occurrence occurs.
If we pass in 26, now it will start searching at position 26 which is the u
here. We'll find at position 47. The final occurrence of audace. So,
seeing the string from position 47 to the end,
starting from here, we see that. Now, we're starting
from position 48, which is this u. We'll get
as our output, negative one. And that's because, although
the string occurs many times in the string danton,
it doesn't occur at all starting from position 48.
And so, the output of find, when the target
string is not found in the search string, is negative
one and that's true if we start from position 48, we
don't find the target string at all in the search string.